so julian is in the car with me we go to
7-eleven
you know i go and i go and i wait in the
line six feet whatever i have the mask
on
and there's a full-blown fight in the
counter with this
white dude you know full-blown is also a
term used for aids only
yeah yeah i try to bring that up but i
yeah it's a pet peeve when people do
that
yeah people are like oh man you know
yeah full you know yeah but he had it
full-blown white really yeah and he was
like
the guy was mr easter
i don't know why but immigrants love to
say that yeah
easter you know yeah mr you need to wear
a mask we can't serve you right he goes
[ __ ] you guys are all sheep you know
he's like doing that in the store
right i'm sorry mr miester right
and then he goes i'll buy a mask
so he bought a mask and he kind of put
it on his face i hate that
right like he put it by like one on an
eye
one of the straps was even around the
ear yeah he's like give him my beer
because he was buying beer oh i'm just
sitting there i'll go don't
we're good don't say nothing bobby you
know i got internal
dialogue and so he kind of leaves i
order and he stands by the door
i don't know why he has a [ __ ] yeah and
now what do you feel like he was waiting
for
because he was already angry at what the
guy who worked there yeah and that
that man was asian no the mr mr guy yeah
no he was a hispanic
why do you sound like that well because
i think that you know what's [ __ ] up
when you say they do that though
is no matter what accent i do right
allow
yeah they go why are you doing an asian
accent right people always do that oh
yeah
because of my face yeah yeah that's true
yeah so it doesn't matter what i would
call yeah it could be anybody that's you
that's on there
yeah so mister easter right so then
anyway he waits by the door
and i go and i order my [ __ ] with a
cigarette i put in my pocket
and i'm going to the door and the dude
opens the door for me and now his mask
is off
because he bought a [ __ ] already here
you go sir
right you now you feel like he was
welcoming or he was he was no
i think he was trying to be nice okay
but then i'm like no dude go ahead
no you go in front of me um right
i could dude no bro you're not wearing a
mask i said
he goes i don't have it
he goes i don't have it like that
right now i look at uh juliana in the
car
and she's just she has her mask i can
see her eyes what the [ __ ] is going on
right
and i go and then and then what do i do
he goes it's a hoax you know what i do
i lie you lied to him yeah
i got my friend died from it damn
right he goes really why he goes i don't
have it i could and then i made a
name i made up a name and i said two
first names yeah my dear friend david
jose
that's why i swear to god my friend i
said two names first name
my friend david jose died from it he's
like i don't have it i could go ahead
and we're now in a full-blown
fight bro full-blown fight julian's in
the car freaked out right
so he just he finally relents and he
just leaves right
and all the halloween candy just came
out that's the worst time to fight it
like a cbs dude
right okay so then i i go outside
and i run the car open and then he comes
to the car
so i remember julianna were trying to
figure out how to lock it oh
yeah it was a whole thing he's like you
[ __ ] liberal piece of [ __ ] i love
you yeah me right you [ __ ] you know i
mean you're a [ __ ] sheep you know
and he kind of looks at my uh driver's
license to see like what my drop
like more of a silk i wouldn't call you
a wolf you know
yeah yeah there he is there david jose
all right dude there is a david o'neill
yeah there is
i don't know man so that guy died yeah
that guy died from the coven but um
yeah good evening good afternoon and
other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you could watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah